on est importante pour l'exécutif
importante pour l'avenir de la réforme
des retraites et que nous allons suivre
en direct sur les chaînes parlementaires
toute la journée alors c'est l'étape
logique après la réunion de la
commission mixte paritaire et hier c'est
cette députés cette sénateur qui sont
parvenus à un accord charge aux deux
chambres maintenant de l'entériner alors
la gauche va-t-elle déposer une dernière
motion le gouvernement va-t-il déposer
des amendements c'est ce que nous allons
suivre Oriane toute cette matinée sur
Public Sénat
en tout de suite pour suivre cette
séance au Sénat ce sera dans quelques
minutes
faut arrêter avec nous merci Audrey on
se retrouve demain pour une émission
spéciale consacrée au vote du Parlement
sur le texte sur le texte final de cette
réforme des retraites on voit tout ça
demain on analyse tout ça à demain très
bonne journée
la presse quotidienne régionale